alright alright alright thank you for
coming to tonight's meeting of
Government Club we are honored to have
mr. ken Silverstein speaking tonight
about his latest book the radioactive
Boy Scout mr. Silverstein is an
investigative reporter for the Los
Angeles Times in the Washington bureau
before joining up with the LA Times mr.
Silverstein freelance publishing
articles and Harper's the nation and
other popular magazines based in
Washington mr. Silverstein crusading
against the influence of interest groups
and politics has written several books
about how the Capitol works his first
major success Washington on 10 million
dollars a day how lobbyists plunder the
nation describe the nation the ways in
which corporations and nation and
smaller nations buy influence from
legislators following up on his
expertise in corruption in the nation's
legislative branch he two years later
co-authored private warriors an expose
on the military-industrial complex the
book explores corruption and defense
spending bills and highlights the
wastefulness of many current military
projects for example he describes
spending on the b-2 bomber which costs
more than its weight in gold
we're researching the book mr.
Silverstein traveled all around the
world researching international arms
sales including trips to a weapons
Bazaar in Rio de Janeiro and a soldier
of fortune convention in Los Angeles his
latest and fifth book the radioactive
Boy Scout features a 17 year old Eagle
Scout who built a nuclear reactor in a
shed in his backyard
mr. Silverstein is a lively writer who
has traveled all around the world
researching his articles so we like to
welcome mr. silver and Cecile into
government club
thank you very much for inviting me your
introduction was really far too kind my
first major success I don't know I've
ever had a major success I think the
radioactive Boy Scout is probably the
only thing I've written that has some
sort of general commercial potential
because mostly I write about politics
and that doesn't tend to be as popular
stories about Eagle Scouts who try to
build nuclear reactors in their backyard
anyway I am as Dan said the book is
about it's a true story I am frequently
asked and people frequently say to me
it's impossible this can't have happened
and that's based I think on a slight
misunderstanding he didn't actually
build a nuclear reactor in his backyard
that would be impossible he tried to
build a nuclear reactor in his backyard
and it was part of his effort to get an
atomic energy merit badge because he was
trying to become an Eagle Scout he
didn't as I said actually build the
reactor but he did get far enough that
the Environmental Protection Agency had
to come in cut up his backyard potting
shed because it was full of highly
radioactive materials and send it out to
Utah and bury it at a low level
radioactive dump site so it's a pretty
remarkable story but he didn't actually
build a reactor that is well beyond the
talents of any teenager and I want to
stress that only because people
constantly even the reviewers of the
book one of the reviews which I
shouldn't complain about because it was
quite a nice review but it started by
saying how close was suburban Detroit
where this story unfolded to becoming an
American Chernobyl very close according
to Ken silverstein well actually I
didn't say anything like that he wasn't
any anything close to American Chernobyl
I mean this was not a Three Mile Island
this was not a nuclear meltdown or a
nuclear disaster it was a potentially
serious problem that was dealt with and
you know you had highly radioactive
materials floating around it was a
problem it was not a Chernobyl I mean
that is a ludicrous comparison so what
one of the reasons that it's important
to keep this in mind to sustain a
nuclear
chain-reaction you've got to have at
least 30 pounds of highly enriched
uranium to actually build a nuclear bomb
or to build a nuclear reactor is not
terribly complicated and you can go on
the internet after this talk and you can
download very quickly a very very good
diagram of how to put together a nuclear
bomb but the reason so few countries
have nuclear bombs or nuclear reactors
for that matter is that obtaining highly
enriched uranium is not easy it's a very
complicated very expensive process it
requires an investment of tens of
millions of dollars a very very
sophisticated scientific establishment
so this is you know I just want to get
that out of the way fast so that nobody
at the end says oh it's impossible you
know he couldn't have done it let's just
be clear on what he did he didn't build
a reactor I'll also say that the book is
not I'm not as probably most of you here
know far more about science than I do
which is one of the reasons it took me
six years to write this book it was
based on an article that appeared in
Harper's Magazine back in 1998 and I
really had to learn a lot about nuclear
nuclear physics the basics of it but the
book is not a heavy read I don't think
it's really quite an easy read partly
because I don't understand the science
so well I understand enough that I could
write the book and partly because the
science really isn't that complicated
believe it or not I think you'll see
when I start describing what David Hahn
did um I've said he didn't build a
nuclear reactor what he did do though
was to obtain a number of very very
highly controlled and very dangerous
radioactive materials I'll describe how
he did it in a moment and he put them
together in a way that appeared to
increase their inherent radioactivity so
again he didn't build a reactor but he
did something pretty extraordinary one
of the things I really wanted to
get in the book is how did he do it how
was he able to do this I mean this is a
backyard project for the Eagle Scout
it's not easy one would think to try to
build a nuclear reactor without somebody
putting a halt to it and one of the
things that I kept coming across in
researching the book was that the
David's parents the adults in his life
and his friends all seem to be fairly
oblivious to what he was doing there was
no real checks on undated and it allowed
him to get to the point where a federal
intervention was required to shut down
his laboratory he he got interested in
science at a pretty early age around 10
up until that point he had been quote
normal I mean he liked basketball he
rode his bicycle around the neighborhood
you know he played soccer and then he
got from his step grandfather a book
called the golden book of chemistry
experiments which if any of you can get
your hands on it it's very instructive
it's a very fun book unlike most of
today's science books for kids it's
actually quite amazing to compare the
golden book which was written in 1960
which was you know this is when JFK was
talking about putting people on the moon
you know you had the Russians with
Sputnik this was an era when science was
emerging and it was thought that science
could cure all of our ills the golden
book of chemistry experiments taught
David how to make chlorine gas it taught
him how to make chloroform it taught him
how to blow things up which of course
every 12 13 14 year-old boy wants to do
I mean what's more fun than blowing
things up with chloroform he actually
made his homemade batch the golden book
the only caution the golden book gave to
David or to any of its readers was don't
breathe too deeply and of course being a
fourteen-year-old boy he breathed too
deeply and he said that he ended up flat
on his back he didn't know for how long
but it knocked him out cold
now you go into a bookstore today and
get a comparable book for four kids and
it's really amazing you know the
experience I think we may have been
really lawyer does a culture or
something because everything is risk
free I mean the golden book could never
be published today the the ones today
they're no moving parts no electricity
god forbid there should be a flame
because that could be terribly dangerous
and so you end up with experiments like
building a were Marie or let's have fun
with the wind and these are real titles
of experiments that I found in in
today's science books for kids but David
you know his mind was just the golden
book really Unleashed this fervor and
passion for science and one can see why
if you go back and look at it meanwhile
he has a somewhat unusual home life that
plays a very important role in how he
proceeds on this nuclear science
scientific trail his mom was very very
loving woman very sweet but she had some
some mental problems and she was very
removed and the times not in David's
life for periods she that his parents
were divorced when he was pretty young
and they both remarried his mom
remarried a man who was a truck driver
at a GM plant neither one of them had
anything beyond a high school education
and in part I think because of that they
were awed by David they saw this kid who
he'd stay up all night reading the
Encyclopedia Britannica they'd wake up
in the morning and he'd have fallen
asleep surrounded by books and I think
they were almost overly awed by David's
mind and so they never really challenged
him or questioned him he he'd work out
he had a potting shed in the backyard
that is at his mom's house and he'd work
out there until 3:00 in the morning and
sometimes after working out there he'd
burn his clothing and some you know he'd
go in there with a gas mask these are
things that you know might have tipped
off some parents they might have said
what are you doing out there
but when I talked to his mothers his
mother's boyfriend he said well we
didn't know what he was doing but we
figured it was better than drugs and so
we didn't really
challenge them too much and you know we
he said we thought he looks sort of cute
in the gas mask so we just let him do
his experiments out there so they were
utterly shocked when as it turns out the
EPA came knocking at their door and said
gee you've got this problem in your
backyard that we've got to deal with his
father was a you know a good father very
involved but somebody who worked from
early morning to late at night he was
away quite a bit and he was very
preoccupied with his own work he was an
engineer this all takes place in Detroit
the automobile culture of Detroit is
something you can't miss if you spend
any time in the city just about
everybody it seems works for the
automobile industry his dad was an
engineer and he was just not around the
house all that often and so there wasn't
a lot of direct supervision um David
after he got the golden book started he
turns his his bedroom into a laboratory
and he literally destroyed it I mean
there were explosions that damaged the
walls he got he was making mixing
chemicals and spilling them and the rug
had beat the rug was destroyed they had
to rip up the carpeting at one point and
redo the whole room and so they decided
we better put him down in the basement
where he can cause less damage so David
moved down to the basement he built a
laboratory down there and he slept he
moved his books down there he'd sleep
down there and one night his dad and
stepmom were watching TV in the living
room and they heard this enormous
explosion in the basement they go
running downstairs and David is flat on
his back there's the room is just filled
with smoke it turns out David had been
pounding on red phosphorous this was
part of an experiment realize that if
you he was still very young I think it
was only about 14 at this point he
didn't realize that
pounding on on red phosphorous can cause
it to detonate he was this was part of
an experiment for a rocket he had a real
strong obsession with building rockets
and so this was going to be fuel for one
of his rockets anyway he had to go to
the hospital he would be wearing a
plastic mask and that they literally had
to pluck pieces of plastic out of his
eyes he had to go to an ophthalmologist
for a year
no permanent damage but this was a sort
of thing that in many households would
just have triggered real alarm bells but
it was such a sort of routine occurrence
in the Han household that it was just
all these things were shrugged off I
mean on one occasion he um his father
found some strange candle like substance
floating and what looked like a little
tin of oil which he took to parents
night at the local school and he went up
and talked to the teacher and said what
is this I can't figure out what it was I
found it in the basement my son won't
tell me it turned out to be sodium which
if he had actually plucked it out of
this oily substance that it was setting
in would have detonated it's extremely
extremely dangerous and volatile and
it's it's kept in this tin of an of an
oil to prevent it from doing that but
all of these things strange things were
happening but nobody ever really thought
to put a stop to David's experimenting
so he just kept getting deeper and
deeper and deeper into this I also think
that I'm in part as a teenager I think
it's you frequently don't feel like you
have a lot of control you you don't you
within David's case this was certainly
true his parents were divorced which was
a cause of course of unhappiness he he
excelled at science and this was I think
the first thing that he was really
really terrific at I mean he was you
know he played soccer fine he played
basketball fine but science he was just
absolutely brilliant at he every 4th of
July he would make his own homemade
fireworks and everyone would be amazed
and you know he would get all of this
positive attention so I think science
fulfilled some sort of inner need for
him he was good at it it gave him a
sense of control which he didn't have in
the rest of his life and that too I
think led him to continue no to pursue
these these experiments I said that he
adults in his life including his
teachers were a little bit oblivious and
his friends were as well he had a
girlfriend
who
was a couple of years younger and she
said that she didn't know what he was
talking about he'd be talking about
uranium he'd go off on some lung riff
about uranium and she said she said to
me um you know he'd say he'd love to get
his hands on uranium what she said she
said to me and this is a direct quote
quote I didn't know anything about
uranium even that even that you weren't
supposed to have it in your house I was
like whatever so again you know most
people I think who hear oh my boyfriend
wants to get uranium might have thought
to talk to somebody about it but for
whatever reasons nobody nothing ever
triggered alarm on the part of the
people around him his um his friends at
the school also didn't take the whole
thing seriously he talked about doing
scientific experiments he talked about
experimenting with the radioactivity he
even came in one day with a radiation
burn on his arm and one of his friends
said to me well you know I figured the
most that would ever happen is that he
wouldn't be able to have any kids so
again another opportunity lost too for
somebody to sort of keep a closer eye on
him okay so what does David actually do
his original idea he didn't start off
thinking about building a nuclear
reactor he started off with this idea
that it would be neat to collect every
item on the periodic table of elements
and as one of his physics teachers said
to me I thought it was a little weird
you know it mean at his age I wanted
owned an automobile and he wants to own
every item on the periodic table but it
seemed harmless enough so David goes out
and he starts collecting these things I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with the periodic table that a lot of
the items on the periodic table are not
scary or dangerous and you've got
calcium nickel gold copper so these
things of course are very easy but David
decides that he also wants to get the
elements at the higher end of the table
and that's where you start getting into
the radioactive materials so what does
he do he some of the
aren't so hard to obtain actually as it
turns out one of the things I learned in
researching the book was that a lot of
radioactive elements can be obtained in
household items or industrial tools
which you might be able to get your
hands on for example in terms of a
household item smoke detectors contain a
small chip of americium which is a
radioactive element and that's it's a
little silver chip in in the detector
which actually triggers the alarm so if
the smoke starts building up at the
house it's the americium that triggers
the alarm and lets you know get out of
the house he got some of these when he
was away at a Boy Scout camp the other
boys in his group were breaking into the
girls camp and david was while they were
away stealing the smoke detectors from
the ceilings of all the cabins that they
were staying in and then he also he was
always extremely clever he he would Don
a variety of disguises sometimes they
were you know he'd say the simplest ones
would be I'm a student working on a
project so he rode away and I got copies
of the letters actually he wrote away to
a smoke detector company and he said he
was working on a school project and he
needed I can't remember exactly what the
reason was but he needed as many smoke
detectors as he could get and the nice
women in customer service wrote back and
said well that's just great we happen to
have lots laying around uh but I think
it was a discontinued model so suddenly
a hundred boxes of smoke detectors are
arriving at David's house in suburban
Detroit and he's extracting the
americium chip and welding it together
in his backyard to make a ball of
americium which he wants to create a
Neutron gun which you can use Emery
seemed to create a neutron gun which you
can use to irradiate radioactive
elements and make them further
radioactive he had other very clever
disguises as well though I mean he and
I'll get to this in a little more detail
later but he at one point became
Professor David Hahn and he was a
physics professor at a local high school
in Detroit writing letters to the
nuclear industry and to government
officials you know desperately wanting
to enrich his students lives and writing
away for material
ostensibly he was going to be teaching
his students but in fact information he
needed to try to build a nuclear reactor
unbeknownst to the people he was writing
to in addition to americium he also gets
radium which is I can't remember now
even it's in the book I think it's got a
half-life of something like thirty
million years or something and it's
highly radioactive a very dangerous
substance how does he get radium back in
the 20s and 30s and even in fact a
little bit later radium used to be
painted on the dials on the face of
clocks if you even today if you go to an
antique store and you find an old
antique clock which is exactly what
David did it will almost surely have
been painted with radium to make it glow
in the dark they stopped doing that
because they discovered of course that
radium kills people and what happened
was that there was a very famous case of
the so called radium dial women these
young women all women in the 1920s the
early painters of these clocks they took
that little paintbrush they dip it in
the paint this tiny little vial of paint
because it was extremely expensive and
then they make a fine point in their
mouth with the paintbrush and many many
of them died a terrible death of cancer
so at that point or at some point they
decided we better not do this anymore
and they substituted phosphorus I think
initially radium will glow forever
phosphorus last five or ten years so you
have to redo it but phosphorus doesn't
kill you so that's you know the bit the
benefit there anyway David would go to
the junkyards and antique stores and
he'd he he had a Geiger counter and he
would test these these clocks and he if
they were highly radioactive he got a
big big reading from his Geiger counter
he'd take it home and then he'd scrape
off the the paint and then he just he
came up with a means of them purifying
it and manipulating it so that he he
never made pure radium out of this
radium paint of these radium paint chips
but he turned it into something that was
pretty dangerous he his big find and I
went to the antique store where he got
it and talked to the owner
he went into an antique store in
suburban Detroit he was driving to his
girlfriend's house and he goes in with
his Geiger counter what he was always
wandering around suburban Detroit with
his Geiger counter he goes in and he's
testing these clocks and he gets this
extraordinary extraordinary clicking
from his Geiger counter on one o'clock
and he buys it and he takes it home and
this was his big haul it turned out that
the painter of the clock you know
probably 30 or 40 years earlier it was a
wall clock a big wall clock had left a
vial of radium paint inside the clock
and so that was his big haul of radium
he also got um thorium this was maybe
the most remarkable thorium can actually
be used like uranium in a nuclear
reactor it's an alternative fuel and he
um Coleman gas lanterns there's the the
there's a piece called the mantle which
looks like a little doll sock it
conducts the flame in one of those gas
lanterns those used to be coated with a
thorium dioxide I don't believe they are
anymore possibly because of David Hans
experiments I don't know but I think
they've stopped using thorium David got
he went to a surplus store a camping
store and he got huge quantities of
these old lanterns and he took the
mantles out he crushed them up he
purified them it later turned out when
it was tested by the EPA that he had
purified thorium to a level 8 times
higher than the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission requires for a license so he
took these very common items from a gas
lamp from a gas lantern and turned it
into something extraordinarily dangerous
and that was going to be the fuel for
his um for his nuclear reactor then as I
hinted at a little while ago whenever he
gets stumped because David he's very
interesting I mean he was a terrible
student I mean he does report cards
which I got copies that were just mostly
you know seasonal most really mostly DS
he the only thing he was really good at
was science I mean in fact when I met
him if you talk to him about anything
but science he seemed like the most
average kid in the world but once you
talked to him about science it was like
and this is the way his girlfriend
drived it it was like a switch it was an
on-off switch and he just suddenly you
just couldn't keep up with him I mean I
remember his his girlfriend's mother
told me that they had to coach him for
weeks before though she got she got
married her second to her second husband
she said because they go out to dinner
and David would break down the prime rib
or whatever they were eating into it's
chemical compounds and so she had had to
coach him for weeks before the wedding
and said look David you can come you're
a nice kid you're very presentable but
don't talk about the food to the guests
at the wedding this but what this is
typical of the way he thought I mean on
science he was absolutely brilliant on
everything else you'd think he was the
most average kid in the world
in any event there are things he doesn't
know I mean he's dealing with pretty
sophisticated experiments he um when he
gets stumped he contacts the nuclear
industry or the government the
Department of Energy or the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission and here he's
always posing as Professor David Hahn
and I got copies of some letters that he
got from the Department of Energy one
thing that was really stumping him was
that he um he had built a neutron gun
and he was trying to radiate his thorium
and it wasn't working he was testing it
with a Geiger counter and it wasn't
getting any more radioactive and so he
decided I've got it fine I what's wrong
I'm doing something wrong so he writes
the Department of Energy and he got back
a letter that I had a copy of that I
still have a copy of in which he had
asked um you know he posed this is
purely a hypothetical question of course
he didn't say I'm building a nuclear
reactor in my backyard but he asked
about how could he get thorium to absorb
neutrons fired from a neutron gun to
make it more radioactive and he got the
answer from the Department of Energy he
needed tritium which is a gas and it's
used on highway exit signs the reason
that you can see him at night is because
they they contain tritium they're used
you know if you go to the movie theater
the emergency sign is usually lit with
tritium it's also used in
glow-in-the-dark gun sights and
bow-and-arrow sights and David used to
order he
he ordered these gun sights he got hit a
credit card
he ordered gun sights he figured out a
way of extracting the tritium and then
he'd return it and say the thing is
defective and I actually didn't I didn't
believe this because I couldn't
understand how he could have done it but
his father told me that he got a call
one day from a gun store owner who is
furious with David because he had bought
I don't know ten gun sights and returned
them all is defective and the guy said
they weren't effective they were good
and so his father had to pay for him and
he may he made David pay him back that
was his punishment but he'd you know I
kept David would tell me stories and I
would doubt them but then there would be
evidence that they really were true and
of course the ultimate evidence was that
the EPA had to cut up his potting shed
and buried in Utah I mean I have the
documents detailing the cleanup and so
when you see that you know that whatever
he did if he embellished anything he's
not guilty of tremendous embellishment
um anyway I'm going to try to quickly
close this up and just take questions if
you have any what happens in the end is
that David gets nervous because he's
testing he I've skipped an important
step at a certain point he collects all
of these materials he's reading one of
his Cup his father's old college
textbooks and he comes across a
checkerboard schematic of a breeder
reactor a type of nuclear reactor and
David thinks huh that would be sort of
neat if I could put together a nuclear
reactor a model nuclear reactor I mean
he knew he couldn't actually generate
electricity so he fashioned he takes his
materials he puts his story UM's you
know like little bouillon bouillon cubes
those little soup cubes he takes the
thorium ash and the uranium which he got
small quantities of but not very good
not very pure and he puts that together
into these cubes and then he puts his
Neutron gun at the center of the thing
thinking that it will irradiate these
elements that he's put in a in a sort of
checkerboard diagram the cubes will
never really know what happened David
said that he got nervous because it's
you know he was
measuring the this little model reactor
in that it was becoming more radioactive
he decided at a certain point that it
was dangerous and that he should shut
the thing down so he he puts together he
he takes his his model breeder reactor
apart we're only talking about something
the size of a shoebox I mean we're not
talking about like you know anything big
at all he he he disassembled it he
throws everything in the trunk of his
car and to make a long story short he
gets stopped by the police the police
open up the trunk of his car because
David's very nervous and they discover
all of this weird stuff I mean there are
cubes back there there's all sorts of
like mercury switches there's a there's
a toolbox that is taped shut with
electricians tape and the police decide
this is at 3:00 in the morning that it's
an atomic bomb or possibly an atomic
bomb and the David is a teenage
terrorist which he not he was not I mean
he never had bad intentions I want to
stress that anyway what's sort of
amusing is that the police for some
reason which has never become clear
decide to tow a car containing what they
think is an atomic bomb to their
headquarters and then they go oh no we
may have an a-bomb in the parking lot
and they have to quarantine part of the
parking lot and notify the authorities
in Lansing Michigan the state
authorities and they did I mean they
contact the state authorities who
contact the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission and they have a full-fledged
little mini nuclear crisis on their
hands and in the end you know they come
in they test the material they discover
it's not a bomb but they discover that
the things in the car are dangerous and
they are highly radioactive and then
again I'm going to bring this to a close
quickly they they not for a few months
but they've discovered the potting shed
in the backyard of his mother's house
and when they went out there and tested
that you know I got the report of their
tests and I again I can't remember for
sure the numbers but they found very
very high levels of radio radiation
coming from I'm not going again I'm not
talking Chernobyl levels you know I'm
just talking about levels I think up to
5000 times
background levels of radiation you know
on items like a pickle jar or you know a
piece of carpeting I mean this stuff was
just spread around the shed and his shed
this was not a sophisticated laboratory
he was using you know coffee cans and
coffee filters and this sort of stuff
and at that point they decide we got to
do something because people in the
neighborhood could be at risk if the
materials seep out of the the potting
shed that's what led to the federal
intervention that's what led to the EPA
coming in and to the horror of the
neighborhood they wake up one day and
these men in moon suits are running
around with chainsaws cutting up a
backyard potting shed they don't know
what's going on and they're not getting
a lot of information it caused quite a
panic in the neighborhood and as I said
they they sent it out to Utah it was not
classified as high a high level radiate
radioactive waste you know but they did
have to bury it out at this place called
enviro care in Utah where I mean you've
got stuff buried out there from a mere
you know from this country's nuclear
weapons programs I mean it's it's it's
not the worst of the worst but it's it's
stuff that has to be treated very very
carefully and I think at this point I
will just bring it to a close and ask
you if you have any questions
actually yeah I have a question um when
your it was missionary that you're an
investigative reporter when you're
investigating a story where do you draw
the line with something that's going I
mean where do you find a balance between
something that's going to expose Iran
and something that's actually hurting
people who might be trying to do good
because obviously you can have a
conflict sometimes um you know I I guess
I'd ask you for an example uh well I if
I can I I guess one example I mentioned
here that was the example of these
researchers at NIH who were cited for
taking consulting fees which Ian granted
these are public servants who are taking
a considerable pay cut from private
sector jobs and they're trying to earn
some extra income to support themselves
I mean where are you in that case you
know draw the line between a conflict of
interest and someone trying to provide
for their family well in that case I
can't I don't want to talk about that
case cuz it's not a story of mine but
it's similar to a lot of stories I
worked on I mean you know III don't know
really how to give you an answer I guess
what I'd say is that when I develop a
story or anyone yet our newspaper
develops a story we talk to editors
about it and there's a conversation
about is it a story or not and sometimes
you you think yeah this is a real
problem and this is something we should
go after and this is something we should
report out and other times you go this
doesn't you know this doesn't really get
over the threshold of being a problem
and we're going to drop this story and
of course sometimes the most frustrating
of all is where you go this is a problem
but you can't pursue the story because
you can't get access to the information
so you're always trying to figure out
what's a good story and what is
something that we should be spending our
time looking into and you know there's
no hard and fast rule obviously it's not
like you can plug it into a computer and
go yeah okay this is bad we should
report this out you have a conversation
with your editors you
conversation with other reporters maybe
and you determine whether you have a
story so it's it's you know I can't give
you any sort of hard and fast rule I
think generally generally it's pretty
easy to get a sense of what what's
something that's going to make people
mad I guess that's one of the things
that I think about in looking at an
investigative story is does it make me
mad is it likely to make my parents mad
I mean when people hear about this are
they going to go that's just wrong that
shouldn't happen but you know again it's
not like there's a calculus that you
make on paper you just figure out to
sound like it's going to make people mad
I guess that's my that's the only rule I
can think of yeah how do you first find
and also like a slip larger like how do
you usually find out at school my keys
and that's to ERISA like tip you offer
so that you find out about yourself
well it's I mean in the case of this
book there's an organization in town
called the National Security News
Service and a reporter there had heard
about this story it never really got
much attention it was pit it was picked
up in this some of the suburban
newspapers in Detroit picked it up the
AP did a story a short story that got to
I think was published in the Detroit
paper in the Chicago paper but it really
didn't get a lot of attention and he had
heard about it and they developed
stories and then take them to
journalists and you know go okay here's
what we found out and then you report it
out and find out you know fully develop
the story so that's how I first heard
about it you know in my experience it's
it's really a mix I mean it's generally
it's not you know I think there's a lot
of times people have this idea that you
know people are calling up all the time
with great tips or you know you open the
mail one day and there's a package of
explosive documents explosive in the
sense of exciting and interesting not a
bomb of course and and you're suddenly
you've got this amazing information it's
usually a lot more work than that I mean
I frequently am working on one story and
it leads to another
because once you start looking into
something usually when you print a story
you've probably done what goes into the
paper is about 1/10 of what you've
learned there are all sorts of little
subsets of issues that sub issues that
come up that are really interesting and
ideas grow out of that but I guess I'd
say about 70% of the stories I get are
stories I developed that I you know
however you know I come across them and
then sometimes you do get really really
good tips I mean a recent story I did
was on a member of Congress from
Pennsylvania who's a representative Kirk
Weldon of Pennsylvania who's 29 year old
daughter hope who had I think she had a
undergraduate degree in education and
graduate degree in information
technology I as I recall 29 years old
opens up a lobby shop in town a
consulting shop and within six months
has a million dollars worth of contracts
gee how did that happen she didn't have
any experience well it turns out that
all of the clients were companies or
organizations that her father as a
member of Congress had relentlessly
promoted and done favors for and that
was one of those relatively unusual
stories where somebody comes in with a
tip and says boy you're not going to
believe this but that doesn't happen all
that often you know I think ever since
Woodward and Bernstein and deep throat
there's this idea of you know people
lurking around parking garages with hot
stories that they turn over to reporters
but it's not been my experience
unfortunately doesn't happen too often
so I was just wondering um what David
his family's like thoughts or opinions
either like before or after reading the
story where it seemed like you talked to
conserve all times just one well it's
you know it was a hard book to write for
a number of reasons one of them is
something you've pointed to which is
that a lot of the story is very personal
and sensitive and you know there are
very sad parts to this story it's it's
not you know necessarily the most it's
not like the feel-good story of the
years you know where everybody's going
to be happy about it I tried to treat
everyone I interviewed with sensitivity
and I tried to deal with a story in a in
a compassionate way on the other hand
you know it is a pretty amazing story in
Ferol you know I think David felt like
the book showcased him in many ways you
know I mean he was a young man between
the ages of 14 and 17 who was doing
something really extraordinary and so I
you know I guess you'd have to ask David
for sure but you know for the most part
key and his family were pretty very
supportive and understood that you know
I had to write about certain things that
might be a little bit embarrassing but
that I certainly didn't do it didn't try
to embarrass anyone and I tried to deal
with everything in a pretty sensitive
way and again you know I mean David's
now 29 and there aren't many 29 years
old who had a book written about them
sigh I hope and think that he feels
pretty good about it you know I spoke to
I did I mean I went to Detroit think
three or four times spoke to him and his
family hundreds of times literally on
the phone as well as the personal visits
so we have a pretty good relationship I
just talked to his father yesterday in
fact yeah I was wondering he mentioned
that he wrote several
letters to government agencies as a
different as a professor I was weren't
any first of all if you talk to anyone
about that those agencies and how they
felt about not only about mcbean yeah
it's sort of con to that but also about
like about how a certainty no kid could
know so much about something about
nuclear reactors it such information and
also have you if have you seen I don't
know if you follow this up in your book
but have you seen any changes because of
people 17 year old kid getting dangerous
reading materials bike yeah write fake
letters well both of those are really
good questions in terms of in terms of
contacting the people in the government
the one person who was David's main
source who had a regular correspondence
with had retired from the Department of
Energy and he had a name that is pretty
common I mean if it had been something
really unusual I probably could have
found him but it was a very common name
there were I get a I don't know if any
of you are familiar with people
yahoo.com you can find just about
anybody through through that but his
this name was too common there were just
too many of them
I mean I they're 100 's and hundreds but
there were about 75 or 80 all over the
country I called the government agency
he had retired they had no idea of how
to contact him that was the only person
in the book that I really had felt like
it would be great to have spoken with
and I wish I had but I could never find
him and I thought in fact that he might
find me because I this was based on an
article as I said for Harper's Magazine
the public that ran in 1998 it got
widely picked up CBS News did a story on
it Reader's Digest republished a part of
the story and I never heard from from
this guy which often will happen you
know the person will either they'll be
happier in this case you might have not
been terribly happy but they'll contact
you and I never heard from him so I
couldn't talk to him in terms of any
changes I don't think there were any
changes because of David Hans actions
again I do want to point out he was not
a
quote bad kid he was not a teenage
terrorist he actually you know he had
this idea that he would create a new
form I discover a new form of energy and
new means of generating energy and that
this would be a very good thing and so
he was motivated by you know a positive
idea even if he did do things that
really I mean didn't endanger others so
much as that he might have endangered
themselves we don't really know because
David um the state of Michigan and the
Environmental Protection Agency told him
that they would let him undergo a
full-body scan which measures how much
radiation you've absorbed and he
accepted then at the last minute turned
it down I think maybe because he was
afraid of what he would have found out
but you know he he
I just because people ask me about this
a lot you know was he up to no good was
he trying to harm people and he really
wasn't in any cases I'm sort of not
directly answering your question which
I'll do now
have there been changes yeah but I don't
think they're really related to David
I'm in part it was the Oklahoma City
bombing that led I think the federal
government took much more tightly
control certain substances including
explosives that David might have found
useful or that he might have been able
to obtain pre Oklahoma City and then of
course with 9/11 I think there's been a
lot more control over some of the
elements that he got his hands on he
some of the things that he obtained for
his experiments I don't believe he'd be
able to get any more so the changes have
taken place but not as a result of his
experiments mm-hm first my first
question was wondering if any like
criminal charges were placed again
and second lady backs like the medical
issues like um given the level of
radiation that he was uh subject to like
what kind of medical risks like is he
prone um criminal charges no the police
were really mad at David I think partly
because they felt really stupid about
bringing his car to the parking lot and
then having to quarantined off the
parking lot but they didn't charge him
because I don't partly I think because
they didn't find a statute that you
could charge him with and partly I
believe because in the end they realized
he wasn't trying to hurt anybody and he
wasn't doing anything there was no ill
intent so there was a consideration of
that but they they didn't bring criminal
charges
the EPA considered also charging his
family for the cleanup which is I recall
came to about $60,000 but they decided
not to as well and I think for similar
reasons they decided it was a teenager
he did things he shouldn't have done but
he wasn't a bad kid and so we're not
going to make his family pay for it in
terms of any damage he did to himself
that's a question that we really don't
know I mean certainly I hope he didn't
do any long-term damage to himself he
once said to me sort of flippantly you
know I don't believe I took more than
five years off my life he was working
with dangerous substances in a small
potting shed and he was grinding them
and burning them and you know changing
them you know turning them into powdery
substances in some cases and so some of
that material obviously was airborne he
sometimes used to gas masks with the
filter charcoal he sometimes didn't he
hasn't shown to my knowledge any ill
effects any immediate bill effects and I
certainly hope that he didn't suffer any
but really it's it's not exactly clear
because he declined to undergo the
full-body scan just don't know um
ever pursue any illegal sources for his
materials and also all what do you think
the story says about the danger of the
availability of nuclear reactor nuclear
materials on on a azomite the stories of
might be positive for international a
dirty bomb for situation you know I I
don't claim to be an expert on this
subject but as I understand it the you
know a dirty bomb is it will would if
one were to go off caused an enormous
amount of panic I mean if a terrorist
organization detonated one in downtown
of Washington DC or any other city it
would really be a terrifying experience
you know if it was known that radiation
was being released from from such a bomb
but I don't think that I think the
psychological impact would be much
greater than the actual impact in unless
they had managed to get much you know
something that would probably serve
better for not a dirty bomb but a real
bomb so David did get a lot of these
items and somebody could go out and get
a lot of these similar items and put it
together into a bomb and blow it off and
it could cause panic I suppose I don't
think though unfortunately I think that
was probably be you know that the
unfortunately terrorists anyone out to
do harm could probably come up with many
more horrible things that they could do
at less you know which wouldn't require
nearly as much effort so I it's a good
question I get asked about it a lot and
it's it's a concern but you know you you
know a sort of common bomb would be a
much probably cause much more of an
impact than anyone going out and doing
these extraordinary things you know
scraping radium off of a clock you know
this is not something a terrorist
organization is really going to think of
and I'm sorry what was your first
question
he sometimes resorted to illegal means
and I guess it depends on how you define
illegal as well I mean is it illegal to
order a gunsight and take out the
tritium and then send it back is
defective probably it might be
considered illegal I mean certainly not
you know something I'd recommend he
sometimes did you know to put it bluntly
stole stuff you know he got his hands on
things by you know like he had a friend
who worked at a at a school at a college
laboratory who got him stuff I don't
know that he ever actually you know he
might have done things that technically
violated some law but he certainly
didn't violate any major laws you know
so mm-hmm
what attracted you enough to the story
to want to run a book about well the
story itself you know sometimes people
come to you with stories that they think
are fabulous and you know they lay out
this story for 20 minutes and the whole
time you're thinking how can I get out
of this this is just a really dull story
but in this case it was pretty obvious I
mean you have a Boy Scout trying to
build a nuclear reactors to get his
atomic energy merit badge and you know
they have to the feds have to come in
and ship it out to Utah for burial
that's an obvious story what attracted
me if I can be completely honest here
instead of giving you some sort of
really philosophical answer was that the
day that the story appeared in Harper's
Magazine and it landed in subscribers
mailboxes an editor at Random House
called me and said this is a great story
I want you to do a book and my immediate
thought was well how am I going to
possibly turn a six or seven thousand
word magazine piece into a fifty or
sixty thousand word book but of course
with the specter of dollars looming out
in front of me I thought I'll cross that
bridge when I get to it I mean if Random
House when it's a book it's a great
publishing house I'd love to write a
book for them they're going to pay me
pretty well and I'll figure out how to
write a book that's the other reason
that it took me six years to do it I had
a fantastic editor at Random House in
fact I had several it took so long to
write the book several of them moved on
their jobs but um the original editor on
the book a woman named Courtney Hodel
was just an incredibly great editor and
my first draft I mean she would have
been well within her rights to simply
call me and say are you joking
I mean this is terrible you've got to be
kidding me I mean forget it the whole
deal's off but instead she very
patiently helped me turn a pretty lame
first attempt and the first first draft
into over the course of several
additional drafts in six years what I
hope is a pretty readable entertaining
book but it wasn't any sense high moral
purpose it was um I was a freelance
writer at the time and anytime somebody
offers you money you take it so I
thought you know and I thought it could
be I thought it could be fun so mm-hmm
this David doing that I was he doing
anything with David um David has a
really obviously a very amazing mind for
science um the one thing that I think
remains to be seen as to whether he can
be disciplined enough and worked in a
sort of supervised atmosphere to succeed
at science
he has floundered around a little bit he
ended up joining the Navy and strangely
enough he was based for some time on the
USS Enterprise which is a
nuclear-powered submarine eight nuclear
reactors on the on the sub and what he
told me was that the Navy forbid him
from even looking you know after the
reactors he wasn't allowed to work in
any way with the reactors because it was
deemed that he had absorbed potentially
absorbed too much radioactivity during
the course of his experiment so he was
kept away from the reactors he then left
the Navy for a time and now he's back
he's in the Marines actually and I know
he still has scientific dreams and I I
know that he still thinks about it and
still may even be pursuing certain ideas
but right now he's in the military so if
he does pursue science it'll have to
wait
ran point the allotments he did should
have turned some alarms but your
attitude towards the parents he was
pretty forgiving he personally think
that they should be helpful for like
this getting completely under control
um no I mean I guess here a couple of
things as I said his mom was really a
loving and really a really important to
David and you know I don't think the
problems that she she had were not of
her own making and she was unable I
think to act
she didn't supervise him the way that
she you know she could have or should
have but I don't really think it was her
fault
I mean his dad absolutely was um he was
away a lot
there were certainly things that you
know he might have taken a tougher line
with David on absolutely but I guess I
try not to be too hard on him you know
in part because he he did love his son
in his own way and I have two small kids
of my own and I know it's very very hard
unfortunately to cast a critical eye
towards your own kids and you're always
willing to give them the benefit of the
doubt and he certainly gave him the
benefit of the doubt too often I guess I
just try not to in this case passed too
harsh of a judgement because you know
sure mistakes were made but again just
like David wasn't a bad kid his parents
weren't bad parents they probably should
have done certain things differently but
I don't know they they they would I
don't know I just I don't think it's
fair to say they're bad you know they
were bad parents it's not accurate
mm-hmm
to be one of the strange things that
this story is the nuclear science merit
badge I was wondering if you could tell
me
sket still have this and what requires
and how someone would normally go about
earning this yeah um yes they still do
have it and what's you know one of the
things about David's story that's so
interesting is it's actually called the
atomic energy merit badge not the
nuclear energy merit badge which is
significant in a way because atomic
energy is such a throwback term it's
straight out of the 1950's and in many
ways David lived in sort of a 1950 sort
of cocoon his his great inspiration came
from the golden book which was 1960 but
you know it had that sort of 50s
optimism about it this sort of
starry-eyed attitude about science and
the atomic energy merit badge was the
same you know very very romantic idea
about science and especially about
atomic or nuclear science one of the
things and you know some of the reviews
I'm happy to say of the book have mostly
been real favorable a few of the
reviewers have said oh the book was you
know very critical of the nuclear
industry I guess what I was critical of
was more than anything was the boys the
atomic energy merit badge the booklet
that David was reading to get his merit
badge and by the way you asked what do
people do well
they build a model nuclear reactor but
not with americium and radium and
thorium with marshmallows and ping-pong
balls and rubber bands and this sort of
thing so David just went a little bit
beyond what they suggested but the
Atomic Energy merit badge was written by
people who were very very close to the
nuclear industry in one case a guy who
worked for Three Mile Island and so it
was extremely pro-nuclear it was very
uncritical I mean it really taught you
know it actually said something to the
effect it you know the some people are
afraid of nuclear energy well they're
sort of like the people who were afraid
of electricity in an earlier era so that
anybody who was critical at all was just
sort of a naysayer and a real stick in
the mud and that you know I mean the
book talked about how the America Japan
had talked about how it wanted to
inspire
you know an open investigation or
something like this into nuclear energy
but it didn't I mean it wanted the kids
to come out pro-nuclear and in fact as I
discovered in writing the book from the
very beginning of the nuclear age the
commercial nuclear age the Boy Scouts
collaborated very very actively with the
nuclear industry the atomic energy merit
badge was something that came out of
discussions between the scouts and the
industry so the whole thing was designed
to promote and support nuclear nuclear
energy and so you know I I guess I found
that a little troubling and it's still
even if you go there's a boy scout you
there's a Boy Scout store out on I think
it's awful Wisconsin Avenue up across
the Maryland border and you can still
get the same merit badge pamphlet that
David used and it's still absolutely
unless they've changed it in the last
year because I saw somewhere around a
year ago still the same stuff it's just
extremely Pro industry this is no
dissenting view and David as I said sort
of lived in this bubble of you know this
50s optimism this belief that the you
know atomic energy could you know it
would it would make electricity so cheap
as the famous saying went it would be
too cheap to even meet her none of that
of course turned out to be true I mean
ironically one of the worst potential
nuclear accidents it was a nuclear
accident it could have been much worse
though was a meltdown of a breeder
reactor in in Detroit the Enrico Fermi
plant there's a book about it called
they almost lost Detroit it it didn't in
fact become a full-fledged meltdown but
he came a lot closer than anybody knew
at the time and it really it would have
made Three Mile Island look like nothing
so yeah
did David ever get its atomic energy
badge he did he did get his atomic
energy merit badge he got it well before
he took these experiments to such a you
know an alarming state after the cleanup
took place there was actually some talk
within the local Boy Scout council about
stripping him of his Eagle Scout status
because he not only got the atomic
energy merit badge but he did get he did
become an Eagle Scout and there was talk
that you know he had endangered people
in the community that he had resorted to
not always honest means of obtaining
some of these materials and there was
talk that they should take it away from
him but in the end they decided not to
and so he maintained he maintains his
Eagle Scout status of your former boss
is better at spending
I was wondering how we thought about the
current human military spending and eggs
whether you saw any I guess miss
spendings or corruption
Bill's I I mean I guess I would say that
the you know the size the current
spending for defense seems awfully high
I mean I think that the the increases
have been pretty extraordinary and some
of it doesn't seem to be targeted
towards fighting which would seem to be
the most obvious immediate threat which
is terrorism you know I mean the
ballistic missile defense program for
example which has been a passion amongst
certain elements of the military
establishment for some time
and in fact there was a story I think
today in the Washington Post about how
Condoleezza Rice on September 11th was
set to give a talk about the
administration's priorities for national
defense and security and was going to
focus on ballistic missile defense I I
sort of thought that
September 11th showed that ballistic
missile defense was not the most
pressing defense need so in turn I I
have to confess I haven't been following
specifically what's contained in the
defense bills and what specific programs
are being pushed in in any great detail
I mean you know I read the newspaper
like everybody else but I've been on
very different subjects so I'm not sure
there but just the overall level of
spending seems pretty extraordinary
particularly given the deficit and
everything else with David's story
obviously at the end of the day one of
the conclusions we can come to is that
we need stricter controls on access to
nuclear materials but what other lessons
can we learn from his story well boy in
terms of the controls as I said before I
think I think a lot of the things that
he could do probably aren't doable
anymore and not because of what he did
but because of Oklahoma City is
September 11th I think some of the items
that he got his hands on might not be is
easily easy to obtain today
eh I guess I never saw David stories
some grand tale moral tale III you know
I thought more of as entertainment than
them then less you know then teaching
some sort of lesson I guess to me the
lesson would really be no great
political saga but really just the way
that a kid like this who with sort of
more supervision if he had found a
mentor I mean I guess it's more a story
about youthful genius or youthful
creativity than anything else and you
know David did some pretty amazing
things if with a little supervision with
with a mentor I it was interesting
actually to compare him I looked at some
of the winners of the Westinghouse
science competition and it seemed to me
that the only thing that these kids did
that David didn't do or not that what
they did but the only thing they had
that he didn't have he never found a
mentor he never had somebody who
recognized his genius for science and
pushed him to develop it in a supervised
way and I guess to me that's that's the
part of the story that I look at and go
gee what if but I I just don't see what
I don't think any terrorist organization
would read this book and go wow that's a
great idea I mean you just wouldn't go
you know if you're a terrorist
organization I mean I just can't see
al-qaeda going to junkyards and antique
stores and looking for you know old
clocks I mean there's just so many
easier and more horrible ways
unfortunately to cause harm and damage
than that so you know I wish I could
give you some great you know moral
conclusion out of all this but I just
see it more as entertainment I guess so
it's my honest answer
mm-hmm you mentioned how the science
book was more
19:50 style and today it's more that's
everyone with worms um considering what
he accomplished do you think it's a good
or a bad thing that we've had that [ __ ]
I'm not going to duck your question but
I don't think I can answer it with a yes
or no
you know the golden book absolutely you
know you read it you just go this is
crazy this is absolutely reckless what
were they possibly thinking I mean in
that section you know it's got all these
really great cartoon characters and
these really colorful pictures and you
know it's really exciting and fun but
then you read it closely and you know
there's a chapter on chlorine and it
talks about how chlorine gas during
World War one was used by the Germans to
great effect and cause people to die a
terrible death the you know the Allied
soldiers and meanwhile it's saying oh
and by the way here's a recipe for
chlorine gas you just go come on I mean
this is absolutely crazy that they would
be teaching you know this in a little in
a book for kids so I guess that's one
extreme but then I I see today's books I
can't believe that any kid would read
one of the books that's put out today
one of these science books you know
let's have fun with science at home and
go I want to be a scientist
I'd go forget it I mean I'd rather do
geology or you know go into anything but
you know anything but learning about
this type of science I mean it just sort
of beats all the fun out of it I mean
really next time you're in a bookstore
check out the books I did a few of them
I mean there may be exceptions but the
ones I saw the experiments were really
dull I mean I just can't imagine any kid
today would would would want anything to
do with this stuff and again as I said
earlier god forbid you should have to
you know strike a match I understand you
know you know a book for five-year-olds
you know what are you gonna do you're
going to make things turn blue and red
okay but you know for teenagers it just
seems a little overly cautious
that that's my view after sitting one
day in a in a student in a toy store and
going through the science books I just
thought boy I never want to go into this
so